الشرطه تحاول مشاهدينا كما نتابع في هذه
اللحظات تحاول فض هذه التظاهرات واخلاق
هذه المنطقه على ما يبدو هذه التظاهرات
التي بدات سلميه على خلفيه الهجوم الذي
نفذه مسنا همم فرنسي بالامس يبلغ من العمر
69 عاما وقام بقتل ثلاثه اشخاص في هذا
الاعتداء الذي نفذ امس الجمعه في الدائره
العاشره في باريس وكان همم بحسب وسائل
الاعلام فرنسيه قال لشرطي عند توقيفه انه
فعل ذلك لاسباب عنصريه اليوم خرجت تظاهره
بالامس ايضا شاهدنا الاحتجاجات واشتباك مع
الشرطه لكن اليوم يبدو انه يسير همم اكثر
عنفا وشد همم بعد هذه الاشتباك 30 شهيدها
الان على شاشه العربيه بين قوات الشرطه
بين المتظاهرين الذين نددوا ايضا بتركيا
واطلقه هتافات ضد تركيا على خلفيه اتهامات
من المجلس الكردي همم تورط تركيا في هذا
الهجوم هذه اتهامات اذن اطلقها المجلس
الديمقراطي الكبي في فرنسا قال ان هجوم
باريس امس هو سياسي مدفوع من تركيا
وطالب ايضا المجلس الديمقراطي الكردي في
فرنسا بتوصيف هذا الهجوم الذي حصل في
باريس هجوم ارهابي